hi there check this out modern
text-to-speech systems have come a long
way in using neural networks to mimic
the nuances of human voice to generate
human-like audio one second of speech
can require a TTS system to output as
many as twenty four thousand samples
sometimes even more the size and
complexity of state-of-the-art models
require massive computation which often
needs to run on GPUs or other
specialized Hardware so this is
generated by a system that Facebook AI
has built and we're going to look at it
it's called a highly efficient real-time
text-to-speech system develop load on
CPUs there's a lot to unpack here but
this is not a paper this is basically a
technical blog post because I think they
built this into their products and it's
mainly explaining on a high level what
they did so they have a real-time
text-to-speech system which means that
you have a you know a text like the
sentence here share on Facebook you give
it to the system and the system comes up
with a sound wave right a sound wave
that says this sentence so if you listen
to it you'll hear share on Facebook and
it has to do that a in a you know let's
say credible way such that it is a
human-like voice because people like
hearing that you know not these kind of
robot old-school telephone robot voices
where they just chunk together words it
has to flow naturally so what you want
to do for this is you want to have some
sort of recurrent neural network or any
sort of autoregressive Network that
outputs basically these samples here one
at a time so these points you're going
to output one at a time and this for
once they say for one second of audio it
can require you to output two or 24,000
of these of these data points right so
24,000 for word propagations of your
auto regressive model that's massive and
if you want to do it in real time and
that's why real time is so impressive is
you have to do this in less than one
second they have to do this 2,400
forward passes sorry
24,000 forward passes in less than a
second okay and even more so this was
already possible I think but it required
you basically required a big data center
with many many many many GPUs in it so
you basically would send your text to
this and it would stream back the audio
and they can do this just on CPUs and in
fact they can do this on a quad-core CPU
in real time in they can generate this
many samples in half a second pretty
impressive so let's dive into how they
do it and they say it's deployed in
portal our video calling service and
available for use across a range of
other Facebook Applications from reading
a support for the visually impaired to
visual reality experiences okay
so first they show this graphic right
here what are they doing so this is
their entire system it is chunked in
multiple parts if you're a deep learning
practitioner you're very very keen on
taking this text and just like giant
neural network and just run it through
and generate audio and to end right this
doesn't really work in this case first
of all because it would be too much of a
to too many parameters to evaluate this
many times but also especially text and
audio are such different modalities that
you'll have to basically chunk this into
individual parts and that's what they do
so they have this linguistic front-end
and the linguistic front and generates
two different things it generates what
needs to be said and how does it need to
be said
so what needs to be said they call this
linguistic feature
the linguistic features there things
like phonemes and so on so that's sorry
they don't even have a title for this
one so the linguistic front-end converts
the input text so this is probably it's
a sentence by sentence thing so this is
one sentence of text into a sequence of
linguistic features such as phonemes and
sentence type okay so these linguistic
features are if it's like share on
Facebook it would be like okay Shh is
one and then a and then these are the
phonemes of share right it would kind of
chunk it into that so that that is much
closer to what we think of an audio
signal this will make one sound this
will make a sound and this will make a
sound so we sort of chunk it into that
and then here the how is it said this
would be for example the fact that share
on Facebook is sort of an instruction
right and this is different from if this
would be a question like if it said do
you want to share this on Facebook then
the what would output much the same
phonemes right here except it's
different words now but but the how
would output a this is a question so as
you can see the information flow right
here informs the later stages this would
then cause at the end of the sentence
the voice to go up because it's a
question right so it is this linguistic
front-end as you can see it still deals
with text it deals with text and it
outputs these these how features and
these linguistic these what features so
the what features now go into an
acoustic model and what does the
acoustic model do the acoustic model is
meant to generate a spectrum a
spectrogram of the sound now we'll skip
this for the moment and go to the neural
vocoder the neural vocoder is a
kind of a standard thing in text in any
speech producing it takes a spectrogram
of the sound and turns it into actual
audio so this here I think they achieve
it with they say something similar like
a wave RNN based on plus like a a CNN so
we'll look into that quickly so the
spectrum the spectrogram of the sound is
going to be a bit of an image and the
image has time on the this axis and
frequency on this axis and then there is
a a it's usually some somewhat like
color-coded but it's just intensity
right so whenever there is whenever a
frequency at a given time is expressed
strongly it will light up so it could be
something like this so over time the mid
frequency is always there but this
frequency right here is not there and
this is here at the beginning so there's
a sort of a way to read this spectrogram
but this represents maybe something like
this represents the not even sure how
much sound this represents but this can
represent maybe something like 200
milliseconds of audio and you have to
basically perform a Fourier transform to
transform that into 200 milliseconds of
actual WAV audio but since the audio has
to be output at what is 24,000 samples
per second what's coming in here is not
that much the acoustic model outputs not
24,000 spectrums per second
so first of all this has to be up
sampled so this time dimension here has
just too few samples so we use the CNN
because this is basically an image in
order to up sample this in order to make
a long image out of this and be
basically the CNN will have to impute it
will have to this is learned right
this is learned how this spectrogram
would look if it were sampled much more
densely and now it has basically the
correct number of samples here and now
this way Voronin can step through it and
look at these slices and look at the
last slices or actually also can look at
the last spectrograms maybe I don't know
they don't really say what the RNN
exactly goes over but this is how I
imagine it and the wave or Ihnen is
based on a wave net architecture and
that means wave net is sort of like if
you look to produce this thing right
here you can look back all the way to
the beginning but you this would be too
many connections right it will be too
much memory so what you do is you can
look back at the directions at the
things right before you in very great
detail but then as you go back further
and further you basically lose detail
see there's only two connections here
within this long stretch where there is
many many connections here at the at the
very beginning so right before you that
means you look in more detail what
you've produced recently but you also
sort of look back in a more blurry way
at where you've produced a long time ago
so this is a wave net architecture and
that's they say they use something like
this in order to then actually produce
the final audio from the spectrograms
so actually a neural vocoder you can you
can train this thing you can train it by
itself right you simply feed spectrums
and you make it go audio and you you
know there's a lot of audio on the
Internet you can simply produce
spectrograms from that and then train
the vocoder to produce the audio so the
good thing about this pipeline here is
you can train a lot of these things
independently from each other I don't
actually know whether they do that or
not but you can you see this box up here
this prosody model
and that will take in these how features
so how does something need to be said
how come on well this is an H how does
something need to be said and it will
transform it into features that the sort
of neural network can understand these
these neural networks they need features
like they need embeddings and as you can
see here it also takes into account the
speaker embedding which is not only how
what the sentence is the fact that the
sentence is a question you would also
get the information that the speaker
should be you know kind of calm sorry
that would be the style the speaker
should be maybe a woman voice and then
the language should be it should have
like an English sound or a German sound
and so on so this model here will take
in all of that and omit features that
these neural networks here can
understand so as you see here the neural
vocoder not only does it transform
spectrograms to audio but it takes into
account how you want the audio to sound
and so does this acoustic model so the
acoustic model is sort of along with the
prosody model is a bit of the heart of
the thing here it takes in these
linguistic features so what needs to be
said right the acoustic model it takes
into account the again the speaker
embedding language embedding and so on
it takes into account the output from
the prosody model of the how you would
like it to be said this includes what
type of sentence this is and this it
synthesizes at all in order to come up
with the spectrum right here in order to
come up with these spectrums so this is
sort of the the heart of the of the
thing okay so about the porosity model
the
say we use style embeddings that allow
us to create new voice styles including
assistant soft fast project and formal
using only a small amount of additional
data with the existing data sets in we
don't have to create a separate model
for each style
we need only 30 to 60 minutes of
training data for each voice style so
that happens because you you take in too
you take in actually an embedding of the
feet of the speakers and you train these
things independently so that means you
can sort of generalize to a new style
really quickly here the they describe in
essence how their acoustic model works
the fact that they output 13 dimensional
MF CC features concatenated with the
fundamental frequency and a five
dimensional periodicity feature which is
much easier for the acoustic model to
generate so that's what the acoustic
model generates okay and then here our
conditional neural vocoders is the final
part of the pipeline consists of two
components a convolutional neural
network that up samples or expands the
input feature vectors from the framerate
200 predictions per second so that's not
it's not 200 milliseconds it would be
200 spectrograms a second to the sample
rate 24,000 predictions per second and
this similar two-way voronin with
synthesizes audio samples autoregressive
Li that means one sample at a time at
24,000 samples per second crazy right so
this all seems like it's a lot of
computation and now they describe how
they get the this to run faster than
real-time and they list their their
individual contributions here so if they
just run this on one CPU core you see it
takes 80 seconds to produce one second
of audio then they do optimized
inference operators which means they
basically use a PI torch get along with
some cities PI torch these PI torch it
which is kind of
where you can sort of compile your deep
learning model to an optimized to an
optimized form that runs faster and they
also customize this so they get to 20
seconds per one second then they do
parameter reduction by sparsa fication
and they are able to abuse the sparse
matrix compute operator I think they
implemented a custom one to do that so
this here is very much like if you have
a neural network and that's somehow
connected connected connected you want
to train it in such a way that it's
sparse meaning that only very few of
these connections have nonzero weights
and because of that you don't have to
store the nonzero weights and you don't
also have to compute because something
multiplied by zero is going to be zero
so you don't have to compute that so
there that they achieve sparsity 60 96
percent right and this basically you do
by some sort of teacher teacher-student
model or there are many ways to do this
but you can you can sparsity regularize
a neural network and basically force
most of the connections to be sparse
while still maintaining a good training
error or a good generalization error so
they supercharge this and with this
sparsity they bring this down to v s/s
and then they go further and do block
wise specification and distillation so
they distill it to an entirely smaller
model that then is also clockwise sparse
so they also enforce this block wise
specification and that not only can you
then have a better operator they
implement this block sparse matrix
compute operator that is specifically
designed to multiply block sparse
matrices they also in the text they
describe that it also optimizes cache
access so if you know about CPUs they
have these level 1 level 2 level 3
Asha's and you can optimize your
computations that's what libraries like
la park and blas do you can optimize
your computations such that your cache
access is optimized and therefore you
can speed up a lot your computations
because the amount of times that you
actually have to go to your RAM and
retrieve something is minimized and that
tends to be the slow part of the process
when your cache misses so again they
achieve 94% blocks parsecity and that
almost gets them to real-time and it's
still one CPU so now they paralyze the
operators that are doing the heavy heavy
lifting to four CPU cores and that
doesn't divide it by four of course
because there's an overhead in
parallelization and synchronization but
that gets you to this one half a second
needed to produce one second of audio so
there you're at real-time and that is
pretty impressive and they go on to
describe so in detail how they did it
but they also give some examples of what
they can do and would like to achieve
even better in the future so here is an
example where they can adapt their model
to a given style and here they have a
British accent
recently we successfully applied our new
approach to create a British accent
advice this is the first of more accents
and languages to come and also you can
adapt it they their idea is that you
have sort of an assistant and this
assistant will be able to adapt to let's
say your mood we're also exploring
features to make our voice respond
intelligently with different styles of
speaking based on the context for
example when you're rushing at the door
in the morning and need to know the time
your assistant would match your hurried
pace when you're in a quiet place and
you are speaking softly
your AI assistant would reply to you in
a quiet voice and later when it gets
noisy in the kitchen your assistant
would switch to a projected voice so you
can hear the call from your mom right so
this this ties in very much with sort of
conversational AI so assistants and so
on but it also ties into wearables I
think so the fact that you are now
smaller then real-time means you can run
this potentially directly on your
smartphone you could run this on your
fridge or something on your stove in
your car without having to stream
basically so you'll get much more
real-time on device assistance maybe
even in your watch and I'm I'm excited
by this technology so far it seems you
can get it in Facebook products but I'm
sure this will come to places all right
if you enjoyed this please consider
subscribing thank you for listening and
watching leave a like if you liked it
and leave your comment if you have
something to comment with that bye bye